you know that the sales for Bud Light
have been declining dramatically and
that's true of even other a b inbev
beverages Bud heavy and other beers now
it's started to level off for the other
companies they're still declining in
sales but the rate at which they're
declining has has leveled off for Bud
Light though it's just a precipitous
drop and now on top of that franchisor
bush has just lost its perfect score
from the Human Rights Campaign that's a
pro-lgbt organization from their
corporate equality index and why did
they lose their perfect score because
transheiser Bush tried to stand in the
middle of the road they're going to get
hit by a truck and they just did get hit
by a truck